Tổng thống Mỹ đơn đơn trăm thông báo của gặp với trụ tịch Trung Quốc tập cảnh bình xin dài trong phòng bỗng tình tới.
Ông nhấn mạnh, một trưng những vấn đề trong tâm được đưa ra thảo luận là tình trạng định trẻ trong nhập khảo đậu tương Mỹ.
Hẹn gặp nhảnh hẹn khẩu Trung Quốc triệu mua bất kỳ lượng đậu tương nào từ vụ 1 thù năm nay.
Tránh ngủ hoàn toàn với cuộc kiến em ngoái khi mà Trung Quốc đặt mua tới sống phải năm trực tấn.
Giếm đến ngày của mấy cơ gây thì thải hàng tỷ đô là cho nông dân Mỹ.
Tổng thống trạng cho rằng Trung Quốc đã lợi dụng đàn phán thù mai để làm giáng đoạn hoàn đậu mua hàng đồng thời khẳng định.
Hôm sinh tình có thể xử dụng 1 thù lượng từ thế quan nhằm hỗ trợ nền nông nghiệm trong nước.
Tháng trước ông cũng để cập đến những tiến truyền chúng ta thận thích chó và cho biết hà bên sẽ nhập trực tiếp tại hàng quốc.
Để bằng thảo có thể giọc hơn từ thương mại mà tuy nghĩ chưa tựa cuộc sông đồ đừng nào u khỏe nè.
Cô gặp sức tởi được kai là phải từ quan trạng được về quan hệ Mỹ trong bố tâm chủd đạn đầy cần thảo.